my first simple cilantro one beans about
2/3 Thai basil make it fresh for the
stinky stank
so there's been a bit of a hubbub I'm
looking at my body in this monitor and I
look like I had the body of a 80 old
Korean woman doing now I'm pretty sure a
lot of you guys out there have already
seen this bone Appetit video and it's
been brought to my attention multiple
times on Twitter Facebook and whatnot
Bon Appetit this article where they had
this white male chef that was telling
people how fun should be eaten if you
don't know what fun as fuzzy is a beef
bone broth noodle dish that could be
done with beef or [ __ ] a could be with
chicken but how I interpreted is it's
like the ultimate Vietnamese comfort
food fills you right into your goddamn
bones doing now people are outwardly
upset about this I've read articles and
posts about people saying oh it's
another way of white people trying to
culturally appropriate you know our food
and whatever whatnot and trust me I
completely get that but here's something
that I want people to think about
because it's been running through my
mind now I watch this video I don't want
to say people are making a big deal for
no reason but a lot of you are making a
big deal for no reason now before you
get pissed at me you sensitive little
big about it like this though the video
was titled how you're supposed to eat
your pho watch the video and listen to
what the guy says he's not really
talking about how everybody should eat
their foot he's talking about how he
likes to eat his foot now whether or not
he's white or Asian everybody eats food
in their own type of way now when a chef
creates his food whether you like it or
not most likely than not they're gonna
create that food for you to eat it the
way they intended simply put from what I
got from the video he's just letting you
know how he likes to eat his [ __ ]
diversity and food is everywhere you are
gonna see a whole bunch of white people
eating our food the way that they want
to for example Chinese food Chinese food
in America is way different than Chinese
food in China in fact Chinese food in
China just called food but we've loved
that [ __ ] don't we when we go meet
Chinese food we love eating that
American
[ __ ] if anything in my opinion the
person that you should be mad at the
most or the people is the magazine
because it's not what he said in the
video per se that I believe that people
are offended about I think people are
more offended about the way that video
was titled which mislead you to believe
that he was telling you that this is the
only way you should eat [ __ ] but I do
understand why people are upset to a
certain point because you know a lot of
the times when we are proud of something
that we have especially you know like
Vietnamese food and fun has become
something that's really like a household
name especially in California everybody
knows what fun is whether you're black
white Mexican or whatever and then you
have this well renowned magazine and you
have this well renowned chef that's
gonna talk about food that's really
close to your heart and the first person
that you're gonna hear about it from or
people who don't know what fun is it's
from the white guy are there no old
Vietnamese ladies with silky ass pants
that can tell you hey that not no way to
do it man and to be honest with you if
you want to authentic fun you wanted to
do a video about it it would be the
[ __ ] funniest video hundred hi
welcome to Bon Appetit today I'm going
to take you how to eat nifer I am
well-known chef fat free not when do it
Rick you want to know what to make how
to make the fat huh the number what come
in man puffy [ __ ] if you come to my red
run I give you menu three second you
don't order you don't know what the [ __ ]
no number three when you eat no [ __ ] you
come to my red run I put a thumb into
your soup that's how I know if I want to
keep my children if I put their thumb
into the soup they say it hurt not my
son you know what a special flavor come
for the father look mom fish sauce if it
don't smell like hooker you don't want
it fresh vegetable fresh like my wife
cook first time I met her the restaurant
looks clean or they say there's no MSG
[ __ ] that [ __ ] this situation really
wasn't that bad and on top of that word
for rating the chef for creating a dish
that he loves whether it's his
interpretation or not and you're
destroying his business for what because
you have personal feelings against the
magazine so you're trying to ruin this
chef we are a cultural smattering of a
lot of different things and it allows
people to take certain things like food
and it
the way that they want most of the food
that you eat right now is a fusion and
interpretation of what it normally was
maybe it's because I'm fat but I just
like food good if you want to add a hot
song and a hoisin that your preference
meant whatever you want that up to you
but make sure you try the soup like a
white boy singing don't don't mum okay
nice